hey what's up guys my name is the Cherno
and welcome to another vlog but this
time I'm along the southern coast of
Australia which is on the great ocean
road in winter man absolutely cannot
wait to get out of here and just go to
Europe where it's summer because I'm
serious even though it's drying winter
isn't that much I'm seriously just I
need I need summer just going to try and
find the beach here
found it
[Music]
so today I just want to build on what I
said last long and kind of give you guys
a bit more detail on what I meant by
some of the points that I made
the last time I kind of gave you guys a
bit of an overview of what it did you
need to do to actually learn programming
and get started with that and I
mentioned that a good way to learn would
be to get some books because books in
general are just going to be higher
quality than the stuff that you can find
on the internet and a lot of you seem to
really dig that however if you like me
you just don't always have the time to
start reading a book luckily for you
Amazon has something called audible
which is eventually in the audio book
library and they have a number of really
really good programming books that you
can actually listen to and to be honest
with you like at first I wasn't really
sold on the whole audiobook idea but
it's actually really really useful to
just have headphones then when you're on
the train traveling to school or to work
and being able to just listen to all
your books without having to actually
physically have them in front of you
another great one is when you're driving
you can't really read an e-book when
you're driving but you certainly can
listen to it through your car radio it's
just a really good way to kind of
surround yourself with more knowledge
and dive more into programming so if you
want to listen to some great free audio
books and help support this channel I
put a link to a 30-day free trial in the
description below anyway back to it so
what exactly do I need to do to get
started with programming like what
exactly is like how do I actually start
if you watch my first vlog you know that
the most important step is actually
starting and actually trying to program
and actually beginning to do it because
if you just spend all of your time
preparing yourself or just soaking in
tutorials you're not going to actually
get anywhere until you start doing their
work but that being said if I don't know
what work to do where do I start how do
I find work where am I going to be
taking in this knowledge one of the
first things that I really recommend is
picking up a book and starting to read
it it doesn't matter what book just an
actual programming book not a
programming book on a specific topic
such as OpenGL or something like that
but just a book on the actual language
most programming works will actually
teach you programming as well as the
language not just exactly that language
there are books called C++ for Java
developers obviously if you don't know
any languages that would be a bad book
to pick up however the general books on
C++ and Java and all of that stuff they
contain plenty of knowledge on how to
actually learn the whole programming
kind of how to get in that programming
mindset not just learn that specific
language I mentioned this a little bit
last vlog but if you're just struggling
to get into that programming mindset if
you if you're struggling to think like a
programmer then 100% that look I would
recommend is code complete there'll be a
link in the description below for you to
pick that up if you want to again just a
suggestion I've read that book it's it's
amazing it's a really good book and it's
great for all for all skill set whether
you're a beginner or you're advanced but
you just want to kind of brush up on
your skills that book is completely
independent of any language it's a
really really good book if you just want
to kind of learn programming as a whole
instead of a specific language so highly
recommend that book I bought some other
books in the description below for all
the other languages and they are solid
however if you had to pick up one
programming book if that's all you can
afford if that's all you had in your
programming book library it 100 percent
big code complete I'm sure I'm sure if
you've hung out with any kind of
programming institutions or workplaces
you've heard the same I'm not even
joking when I say that code complete is
pretty much on the desk of every single
software engineer at EA if you don't
like reading books and other thing you
could do is listen to an audiobook
there's a link in the description below
to audible video pre-trials might be
worth signing up it's completely free
just to see if you like that kind of
learning strategy a lot of people soak
in knowledge really well when people
actually save ask them which is why some
people actually prefer going to lectures
in university rather than reading books
and I completely understand that I kind
of like a bit about if you don't like
that you can watch videos as well
there's plenty of videos on youtube that
will teach you programming I've got a
step up life series going on right now
and there are also plenty of non video
tutorials online just written tutorials
that will also kind of help you out with
programming and teach you how to make a
game from scratch for example the fact
of the matter is there is I'm telling
you all this is that it's really
important to find a good start but once
you do start once you once you have read
that tutorial once you've read that book
it's really important that you start
practicing and you're not going to get
anywhere if you don't practice anything
so one of the best ways to actually get
yourself to start programming is to find
some kind of passion what is it you want
to do why do you want to learn
programming do you want to work at a
game studio do you want to design mobile
applications do you want to build
websites what is it exactly that you
want to do find that and write that down
on a piece of
and put it up on your wall wake up every
morning and look at that piece of paper
on your wall and be reminded of exactly
what it is you want to get done what it
is you want to learn I find the thing
reminded of the goals that you're
failing to achieve every single day can
be a really great motivator for you to
just one day say enough I'm this is the
day I'm going to do it right now find a
project to work on it doesn't have to be
something in the open-source community
or something that your friends are doing
it can be a completely personal project
just find something that you want to
actually do maybe you've always wanted
to make a game like Minecraft but you
have some kind of unique twist to it
start working on that it might sound
crazy for me to give advice such as you
should build Minecraft as your first
game and and to an extent yeah I agree
it's completely crazy however you're
going to learn so much if you strive to
achieve a particular goal learning to
make space invaders or pac-man or pong
might be suitable first games however
people aren't usually excited about that
people don't usually spend hours
learning and being like oh man I can't
wait to make pong again if that's you
cool but for a lot of people that's just
not the case but something like
minecraft might be something that
excites you and because you're excited
by the notion of creating something like
that you'll be more likely to actually
spend time learning how to do that
you'll be waking up every morning or
getting home from school every day and
just immersing yourself in that world of
laying because you really really want to
achieve that goal and that's going to be
a massive help to actually learning how
to write code learn to work with people
right working with people is something
that you're going to have to do probably
for the rest of your life not
necessarily but pretty much yet so learn
how to work with people find a friend
who's interested in programming if none
of your friends are interested in
programming or you just don't know
anyone that's interested in programming
and leave a comment below I've also got
a flak team if you go to select off the
channel comm you can join it's free it's
basically just a whole bunch of people
hanging out in like kind of an instant
messenger format just talking about
programming and working on projects
together so if you can't find anyone you
want people to start motivating you
definitely check that out link will be
in the description below slacked off the
channel
working with people is really really
important because you have some
questions all the time and if you're
really smart you'll start working with
people who are smarter than you who know
more about programming than you because
you can ask them questions about all the
little things that you're confused about
or that you're just not 100% sure about
and they'll probably be able to answer
it like that martial arts wouldn't ask
me a question on a forum or googling it
yourself and potentially getting the
wrong answer asking people questions is
amazing when I first started working in
EA I had a billion questions which no
one at university could answer because
it was far outside the expectations for
the course that I was doing but when I
started working at EA I was lucky enough
to have the technical director of the
entire studio as my boss who basically
sat right next to me and I could asking
questions all day long and I have to say
that in the first week in my first week
at EA I 100 percent learn more that I
did in 3 years of University for sure
because I could ask questions anything I
could think of and I would get an answer
immediately so definitely definitely
work with people how do you learn any
new skill practice time it takes time to
learn lately I've been really into
photography I've been taking photos and
putting them up on Instagram Instagram
comp or fashion the channel link will be
in description below be sure to follow
me there how did I learn that how did I
learn that you skill I've never really
taken it seriously in my life before
this year before 2017 how how did I
improve it how did I get good at it
whilst I'm definitely not saying that
I'm an amazing photographer right now
the way that I improved was I got out
there and I started taking photos I went
to cool places like this with my camera
and I started taking photos of course I
watched videos and read articles and
talked with people about photography as
well but the way that I actually learned
the most is I go out and I start
practicing for example I don't know how
I can capture stars at night well guess
what the only way you're going to learn
is if you go out at night with your
camera with a tripod have a few basic
tips that you picked up online or from a
book or something and just experiment
with it try a 30 second shot to try 20
second shot try a higher ISO you need to
actually get out there and start
practicing and then you can take photos
like this I literally took that last
night it's around Ocampo that's the
channel follow me point is you need to
actually get
out there and start practicing start
actually trying to do something and an
important thing for that is realizing
what it is you want to do right what are
you interested in do you want to write
websites for photographers do you want
to work on a rendering system for a game
engine what is it that excites you what
is it that you want to do you might not
know exactly what you want to do yet as
far as programming goes but that's okay
just go ahead and start somewhere
anywhere and just try to hold range of
different disciplines try writing
graphing code try writing a website try
writing game engines try writing a game
script
try making an AI system doesn't matter
just start somewhere and hopefully along
the way you'll find something that you
really really like learning nowadays is
a lot easier because we have the
internet it's a massive massive place
where people all around the world can
share knowledge in the past you have to
travel to certain regions of the world
to find out how exactly they do what
they do but now everything is on the
internet everything is online and not
only that but it's all indexed and
searchable via a search engine such as
Google it's really quite amazing but
what people seem to forget is that
learning still takes time it still takes
you time to learn something just because
you have the internet doesn't mean
that's it I'm done I can instantly
program now that I cook because I've got
the internet right I can Google or
whatever it is I want I can learn how to
skateboard I can learn how to take
photos I can do anything I want because
I've got the internet yes true you could
learn to do anything that you want but
you actually still have to learn it
yourself right people nowadays just seem
to expect to be able to do everything
just because the Internet is and just
because everything is online and all
that knowledge is there knowledge is one
thing execution is another you to learn
how to actually do what it is you want
to do not just not just have all that
knowledge available that's not going to
get you anywhere it sounds simple but
people just seem to forget that anyway
I'm going to wrap it up there over the
next few vlogs I'm going to kind of talk
about my experience with how I learned
programming exactly and when I kind of
take a more detailed step-by-step kind
of guide to how I got where I am for
those of you who don't know I'm an
engine developer at EA so I'm going to
kind of follow my learning journey not
only how I got to where I was from like
kind of a business point of view but
more or less how I learned what I needed
to learn
get up to that point so then you're
going to get a glimpse of my past and
you can see what I did anyway I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please hit that like button a lot more
vlogs coming your way so I'll see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]